we've seen dozens of migrants leaving
facts to the coast to cross illegally
into Europe what do you make of the
situation there and how is the Coast
Guard acting to prevent but also protect
these migrants yes I mean we are doing
our best for both aspects I mean we need
to protect the migrants of course they
are human beings and it is part of our
DNA to protect them and our
commitments internationally of course
nationally and internationally as well
but also we want to we we are doing our
best in order to to to survey our our
coasts and to to to make sure that
nobody is tempted to to cross illegally
the sea from our
our site and how are you doing that sir
well uh each each one in his own domain
of activity of course but
but it is sure that we cannot as I said
um I mean we cannot protect all the
costs all the time uh 100 percent
mm-hmm
there's been a Crackdown in the capital
on undocumented sub-Saharan African
migrants that's obviously pushed many of
them out to the coast to leave to Europe
as soon as possible how has the current
climate actually aggravated illegal
immigration to Europe so we have really
acted on all fronts as quickly as we
could because we we had the impression
that we were facing a real machine that
just exploded in our face I mean and
this was very um this was very tough and
we couldn't really understand tunisia's
very
well known for being a welcoming country
and very nice part of the world to live
in so it was we were frustrated and we
we thought it was an unfair trial so how
what is the length then between the
president's comments and the authorities
you know cracking down on landlords on
employers who've been you know
accommodating black migrants now as I
said I mean
so many different parts are are involved
in this in this question I had interests
in in just letting the situation like
like that without any information about
it you know people were maybe employing
some of them maybe people who are living
from that dirty traffic traffic of human
beings all of those who of course had
interest in in putting the focus on what
the President should
had said or had it say there's currently
no National Asylum law so although the
Constitution dictates that Tunisia has
to Grant Asylum Seekers Refuge there's
no Asylum law that actually regulates or
safeguards this process how can migrants
then actually get the documentation they
leave they need to live in Tunisia
safely and peacefully not many measures
have been taken in order to facilitate
this day whether they are if they are
legal migrants if they're illegal how to
be brought back to their own countries
with all the protection and when it
comes to the new legislation that we
should be providing we have now a new
Parliament and for sure they will be
dealing with this this issue with others
so um but and beside that Tunisia is
respecting all the international
commitments of the country when it comes
to protection of of migrants how are
they being protected sir what's what's
in place to protect them I think at all
levels I mean at all levels again the
our authorities
even for those who have been who could
have been I mean harmed or anything or
threatened
this can happen in every country I mean
we were as Authority we were not
responsible for what what person was
doing I mean you know that many
individuals could have take this
opportunity in order to to to to to you
know to to act badly this can happen
everywhere we didn't want to give a list
of what is happening outside Tunisia and
other supposed Advanced countries in
terms of racism we didn't want to to
make that list but and we were very
uncomfortable to be put in a corner and
and and and and and you know asked why
this happening in Tunisia et cetera we
were we were very uncomfortable with
with that and we still feel that this
has been unfair with us
so I mean the government can't take
responsibility for the hate crimes that
followed the president's comments but
the president's comments themselves do
you not see them as racist
not at all not at all I was in the
meeting I mean not at all
I mean again people had many had had
concentrated on one element and
forgetting well all the rest I mean the
problem of the the international problem
of migrants is something which is above
Tunisia
it's it's it's in link with so many
different countries I mean why should we
focus on one information specific
information and make of this one a big
thing but would you say that saying that
black sub-Saharan African migrants are a
threat to national identity isn't a
racist comment it is not what the
president has written the fact that you
cite a study or or a book or or an idea
it doesn't mean that you are you do
agree with that or you you are promoting
it or I mean it's one element of
information among some many others just
to go back to Illegal immigration as a
whole Tunisia evidence is pointing
towards Tunisia becoming the next big
Gateway for migrant Crossings Libya has
become more and more unsafe for migrants
to cross what are you going to do about
this and is this the reality
opportunities this is what we are we are
we are convincing try to convince our
partners that they have interest in
having Tunisia back economics economy
and and and and the stable and the
stability of Tunisia is very much linked
with the economy it's not a problem of
of of or political problems that the
political problems are solved between
tunisians themselves and they know what
they want they are backing the president
I mean the process the political process
is there have been protests there have
been Mass protests actually condemning
the president's speech and his actions
no we saw maybe maybe Mass financed yes
but Mass protest no